people dancing shoulder to shoulder
while listening to live music in a
stadium
during the pandemic scenes like these
have been rare to say the least
wow it's great i feel great back to life
500 people were able to attend this
event in tel aviv
as long as they could prove that they
had been vaccinated against covet by
showing a qr code and an id
it's part of a so-called green pass
system which is also accepted by gyms
museums bars and restaurants as
authorities want to demonstrate that
getting covert shots gives access to
gatherings and public events
as of early march more than half of
israel's population had received at
least one dose of the vaccine
a greater share than any other country
but a recent survey found that 25
percent of israelis had no plans to take
the vaccine
did you guys get vaccinated to convince
them volunteers have been walking around
and touting the benefits of immunization
and health workers are offering freebies
that include free drinks pizza and
tickets to basketball games for those
that get the vaccine
if everybody will take the vaccine we
can open all the stores we can open all
the business
and it's very important for the economy
israel is going to extremes to reach its
goal of vaccinating
everyone over 16 by the end of march and
reopen its economy as quickly as
possible
today we are spreading awareness for
everybody to get vaccines
ellie greenfield is volunteer medic at
this market in jerusalem she helped
spread the word by encouraging people to
get vaccinated at a nearby bar
where other volunteers were also
offering drinks the idea here is for
them to come to the bar they'll then
receive a drink a non-alcoholic drink in
return for getting vaccinated there you
go
by early march the majority of people
aged 50 and above had been fully
vaccinated while less than half of the
population under 40 had received their
first dose
those who say they are wary of taking
the vaccine cite different reasons
according to a survey 41 of people who
hadn't yet been vaccinated said they
feared side effects and 30
said they weren't sure if the vaccine
was effective
one issue health workers are focused on
is vaccine misinformation
stressing to people that vaccines have
gone through clinical trials before
being authorized by local authorities
people have a lot of fears because they
hear a bunch of things from different
friends or different news channels that
aren't necessarily true
to help with that we have volunteers who
are out and around in the market explain
to people the importance
answering questions and actually bring
them here
some campaigns focus on the
ultra-orthodox and arab communities
where some have been skeptical of the
vaccination program
the government has also set up a task
force to fight vaccine misinformation
like these employees are doing here in
israel's health ministry control room
and in some cases it seems to be working
a suburb south of tel aviv volunteers at
this pop-up clinic offered goody bags
and free basketball tickets to the first
5000 people to get vaccinated
we tried to do our best to give the
people the the idea
to come and take the vaccine around 85
of holland's residents had already been
vaccinated at the beginning of march
one reason israel is pushing its
vaccination program so hard is that it's
crucial to the country's plan to reopen
its economy quickly
the fact that israel has been so fast in
vaccinating its residence also means we
will probably be the fastest in
reopening our market
citizens who've been inoculated can
register for israel's green pass system
which is meant to help the country
reopen safely and allow activities like
indoor dining to resume the green
passport essentially says if you've been
vaccinated twice
you have access to all these places some
other countries including
saudi arabia and the eu have said they
were considering similar systems for
people who had gotten their vaccines
but critics have raised questions on
whether the strategy could result in a
two-speed system
with potentially unequal access to some
public services and travel
israel says this system isn't affecting
access to essential services
[Music]
for the first time we are allowed to
have a rock concert
but the restrictions still apply so only
500 people
can attend this show there are 30 000
seats and 500 people
but green passes are allowing people to
take cautious steps towards normalcy
the green pass program is great it feels
like things are starting to open up and
getting back to what we were used to a
while ago